up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel
and welcome to morning coffee pots even
though I have quick coffee so this is
water
but before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos
um I don't even know what to shoot for
all I wanted was a million subscribers
now that I got a million I'm like
I guess we're going for two now it's
just
not it doesn't hit the same like I just
think the next big goal is 10 million
you know
but it's like after a million you're
kind of up there I don't know
um okay
so I want to talk about my 2023 goals
so 2022 was a crazy Big Year for me oh
my God
and I want to tell you guys all that I
have been doing this year you guys don't
even know this year has aged me five
this is aged 25 Okay so
last year I'll tell you how I started
the show I've
had my YouTube channel
um and last year I was recruited to play
Semi-Pro volleyball in England and get
my Master's Degree now a lot of you are
like why do you need a master's degree I
didn't I didn't really care about the
degree I picked psychology to study
because I was like oh I all the
psychology students in undergrad
you guys were living your best lives you
weren't doing [__] so I was just like I
want to pick this major because it's
easy and it's cheap because let me tell
you this degree has not been cheap
because I failed too many classes and
that was because I failed I didn't fail
first semester I did second semester
because the YouTube stuff okay let me
let me
maybe my dad says sometimes I offer up
too much information but I'll tell you
why okay I'll tell you why I felt so
it wasn't actually because
of the class okay
pause go to the beginning Okay so
I'm recruited to play there and at the
time I was in a relationship so I got
recruited to go to England and
um so I have this YouTube channel
reacting to stuff on the side
and when I get there
um I had
my boyfriend and I at the time had
broken up so I was just kind of sad and
I was thinking like
me and my friends on the team and like
people around there could do a show on
relationships and
um because what I thought was
interesting about London is London has
people from all over the world
so it was like
I can be there's a girl from Germany on
my team there's a girl from England
there's a girl from America there's a
girl from
um Japan it was just like I was like I
have never been around this diverse
like not even like looks diverse like
literally culturally diverse place so
I was like why don't we get some mics
bring the girls over after this will be
fun we can like talk about relationships
and boys whatever
so
that's why the show is called the
pre-game by the way because it was like
kind of a play on the fact that we were
athletes and I always in college like if
we ever went to a party I always
preferred the pre-game like I just
wasn't big into the parties like the
pregame was fun like you would do card
games and you could like talk to your
friends like parties were just
like loud and everyone's stupid you know
it's just I was a pre-game type of girl
I just like talking to people I liked
and at pre-games it's like your closest
friends that's how I came up with the
show that's that that was the name so I
started the show at the end of February
it was like right when season roughly
ended it was like almost at the end and
a lot of people don't know this whole
time
I have been in school for my Master's
Degree I have been playing Semi-Pro
volleyball and doing this freaking show
and my goal with the show and YouTube
was to make enough money so I could get
a pro contract so the YouTube Thinking
Out of Control I barely can even Market
to overseas coaches I actually they
found a contract for me surprisingly and
I wanted to make like two thousand
dollars a month I really didn't shoot
that high I was like if I make two grand
a month
then
um I can make enough to go pro and pay
and then I was talking to someone on
Twitter like like tweeting at them and
they were saying oh this is the only
time in your life you can go pro da da
da look it guys life gives you
opportunities and I certainly could have
went pro
but I just liked what I was doing with
the show there just seemed to be more
opportunity this way it kind of hurts my
heart a little bit to not do it because
it's like I got so good at the sport
and I love oh my God I love volleyball I
could play for hours on end but I was
just like you know
but like it's going pro you can just say
you went pro and there's no money at the
end of it there's no like Championship
that anyone's gonna watch like you could
make it to the top level of a pro team
and no one's really gonna watch it so
it's kind of like
I've played for years for Love of the
Game I certainly have done that but
it just didn't make sense to me like see
it still makes me kind of sad but but it
just made more sense like okay so the
channel took off right channel got super
big people ask me if I thought I'd get
this big a million Subs in a year I
didn't think I hit a million I put a
hundred thousand subscribers on YouTube
was my goal for 2022. I thought I could
get 100K that was like where I thought
and I also
really found the red pill and like
relationship topics interesting because
I never really heard stuff from the
men's point of view and honestly when I
found out how discriminated like men are
in society how much I was like pissed I
was just like what
and it's you know
I I just couldn't believe and I'd had
some maybe like red pill moments where I
realized stuff wasn't hard was like life
wasn't easy for men
um like you know I had a brother that
tried to commit suicide and I don't talk
about that that much because I'm not
trying to like out his stuff but like
I've had moments where
I've seen that life is hard for men but
what I didn't realize was like just how
Society there's like open misandry
against men and I'm sure at times I've
been a part of it you know like I've
definitely
used phrases that really take
accountability off of women like I
remember I did an interview a couple
years ago and a dude talked about how
his girl chased him with a knife and I
said well what what did you do and like
even that like what the hell why would I
ask that I look back at that interview
and I cringe I cringe
um
so so anyways my point is this we
shell blip I failed my classes for the
spring but it wasn't because of the
classes it was because I was so busy I
forgot that this stuff was due
and well okay the original due date but
in England you can like turn it in late
but the late due date I forgot about and
yeah so I ended up failing these classes
because I'm dumb basically because I got
the time wrong yeah
oh my goodness
yeah so that's that's kind of everything
blew up really fast and that so then I'm
in England and I realized like recently
how much I've just like missed my family
like I haven't got I didn't go to the
Fourth of July this year I didn't go to
Thanksgiving this year and it's just
like
I just miss being like close to everyone
even just being home and like
go into my sister's basketball game so
just it's just been so nice because I've
been home for like a week I don't know
so
yeah yeah so that's that's like what I
was thinking with the the show and it
still hurts my heart a little bit I'm
not gonna be able to say I went pro but
I know I could have I know I could have
um
and my dad just said like he always
would say that I liked volleyball too
much he's like there's no future in
volleyball that's not your future
and like he actually he encouraged me to
go pro because he's like you'll never be
able to do it again but he's like when
it comes to Opportunities like you can't
be passing this stuff up because of
volleyball and I he's a what my dad's
the smartest man I know I couldn't live
without my dad so speaking of my dad
so plans for the channel and I feel like
you guys should be updated on this so my
goals for 2023 I worked so hard in 2022.
I have never been so busy and stressed
in my life I feel like I've aged five
years in six months I look in the mirror
I look so tired I hate it I can't live
like this
I'm not mad I did it the hard work paid
off you know
but long term
I know what the comments are gonna say
you became the Modern Woman you know
what you guys for the last six months
you are probably right because the last
six months have been hell I when I
signed up for volleyball in the show I
did not think this would hit a million
subscribers in a year
okay I'm just being honest I didn't
think that would get that big that fast
so
it got really overwhelming so I am still
on the semi-pro team and I
I have to finish things I started I
started it I need to finish it that's
just how I feel so
I have this for like three more months
but what I decided in 2023 I am going to
live with more balance because I can't
live like this because it was literally
like every night I would have something
and either be a show and a lot of times
people didn't know I had practice before
the shows like on Tuesdays any gray area
show I'm running from practice I get out
of practice I run back shower do my show
like sometimes I have 30 minutes to get
ready
so
can't do that anymore so I'm gonna go
back
and yeah like it would be six days a
week like Sunday was the only night I'd
have off and I just can't I can't live
like this anymore I can't do it I will
have balance in my life and so I was
like I think I'm gonna go to two shows a
week and do documentaries during the day
because it's a little different when you
can work in the day but like this the
night show stuff it's like you're up so
late these people are at my apartment
like it's just exhausting we're also
gonna move the show up another hour we
might get a decrease in viewership I'm
sorry guys I don't care this is about me
Pearl is putting me first the other
thing was I wanted to lose weight last
year and I actually did shockingly with
all this stuff going on I lost
like 15 pounds but I really want to lose
and people will say that I don't have
this much to lose but it's like on a
tall person I'm telling you it doesn't
look like as much like 10 pounds being
as tall as I am like it doesn't look as
much so I want to lose 15 more pounds
and then I'm at my goal weight and I'm
good I'm happy but I just really want to
make Health a priority this year like a
good sleep schedule a good
like being I mean I'm in shape I can
like play volleyball and stuff but I
want to focus on my eating and I also
realized so I have problems like
breathing
um and I think I went to the nose doctor
and I'm also going to my doctor's
appointments like I'm just
I am focusing on health and basically
they said
because I'm on health Twitter they say
You're supposed to tape your mouth but
that didn't work for me and I found out
it's because my nose is so clogged up
because I just have really bad allergies
so I'm gonna go to like a food
sensitivity person I don't know if you
guys care about this I'm just telling
you my life and
because I just have never been able to
breathe right like ever and I just
really want to work on
breathing so I'm going to do yoga this
year that is my goal for 2023 is like I
am gonna relax I'm gonna chill out
I'm gonna
I'm gonna have a boyfriend like we're
gonna
we're gonna we're gonna yeah this is I'm
not living like this anymore I don't
know yeah I can't and the documentaries
I'm really excited to do
um
I just got really burnt out of live
shows oh my gosh because it's like the
same topics over and over again like
documentaries are and one-on-one
interviews I just want to push the
conversation forward so we know that
modern women are delusional right we
know that women have these high
standards men aren't meeting we know but
what I want to talk about
is potential I don't want to say
Solutions because I can't change the
world but like
what I really want to dive into wife
school a lot
um like what can the we as women do to
make this better I want to talk to
um I don't know legislators like why are
the laws the way they are
um is there any way to to switch the
laws I want to talk about
why I want I really want to talk about
the
I want to do a documentary talking about
Andrew Tate and like explaining like why
they demonize him so much even from
conservatives
um yeah and I'm just really excited I
want to interview divorce lawyers talk
about divorce score I wanna
I want to show the problems in society
show potential Solutions and who knows
maybe do like a little dating show and
like put people together like husbands
and wives
um I actually I thought about doing one
with me I was like but I was like no no
no no I can't give the internet that
much
um who knows maybe a red pill Bachelor
we might do if you saw the MTR interview
I don't know I don't know we'll
we will see but
yeah this is what all my ideas for 2023
oh oh my God third thing third thing
if anyone's even still listening at this
point
hiring and moving as you guys know I'm
gonna pick a city to move to we're
probably gonna move in like October time
frame right now I'm only hiring for two
positions personal assistant the
personal assistant ideal would be
someone in the UK that's open to the US
or someone in the U.S that would live in
the UK for a couple months
and then go back to the US now look I
know that's probably not probable or
likely but I'm just saying if I could if
I could have what I wanted that's what I
would do
second thing is a recruiter role
um we're getting a second recruiter but
I don't know this guy from the show just
started bringing me guests so I think he
might have it
[__] like if you want a job so bad that
you'll do it for free and you do it well
um because we're doing a second
recruiter and I had to restructure the
whole recruiting system because the way
we do it just wasn't working
um
so
yeah
um
yeah so a lot of people have been
interviewing me about are emailing me
about like jobs and I put some stuff on
my story the recruiting there was
actually a lot of good applicants for
that but the problem was this guy just
started doing the job and I was like oh
easy enough that's how you get a job
folks
um but in the fall
um
I'm bringing some of the people from the
uh UK
however I don't think I'll bring all of
them so
I don't know we'll see email me we'll
we'll in the fall October
um on top of that I'm also looking for a
CEO my dad was telling me because I
really want to structure the business
where I don't have to manage people and
I can just like bring my ideas and my
creativity about like things we can do
and I really just see someone else like
being in charge of everything
um but the thing is we have to be really
careful with this position because again
it's a lot of power to give someone I
wanted my dad or my brother to do it
but they don't want to do it
prick but it has to be a guy that's
disagreeable
um he has to have experience if it's
someone I don't know and they have to
have experience like running teams and I
want someone that really like has a
sharp like they can pay attention
because my thing is like I just I I
don't pay attention to details and I
need someone that's like detail-oriented
and can really give people clear
instructions on like what to do and is
good with like numbers and stuff so I'm
not looking to be in charge because
I I see a vision of like all the
different divisions that we're gonna do
and like one we're gonna do the back end
of like YouTube channels for people so
like someone that wants to be a YouTuber
I can set you up with a producer
um the thumbnails like everything but
that's gonna be expensive and I was
thinking it's probably gonna be more for
businesses because guys for me to do
that for one of you it's
it's not gonna be cheap because it's
just a lot of work but and then you'll
get
you know two meetings a month with like
my manager it's like a whole package
that's one one area
then we're gonna have the main Channel
area then we're gonna have our talents
so we are signing we signed two talents
and where it will keep those and I think
we might sign one or two more maybe but
for us to sign a talent it has to be
really specific so
I would prefer to sign someone that's
like a divorce attorney or maybe a a
therapist but like from a more red pill
lens
um or someone that just does like a lot
of a lot of experience in one field
um because you have to think about it
from our perspective like what makes you
different what makes you special so if I
was gonna do your channel um but that so
the people that would have us do the
back end of their channels like we don't
own their channels but these people like
we would own their channels for a
certain amount of time and they can like
take it or leave it
um
and then so with under the just pearly
things
we're gonna have
and this kind of goes more with the back
end marketing like YouTube courses the
number the just pearly things we're
gonna do merch um
guys okay okay I gotta tell you this
we we're dropping we're gonna we're
working on putting a website together
we didn't want to drop the beautiful
Majestic creature merch on YouTube
because we were afraid
of getting de-platformed
but it might be coming soon let's just
don't tell my manager don't tell my
manager just keep it a secret okay
um but for the the second division under
the just pearly things there's gonna be
merch
newsletters and the third thing I'm
really excited about is events I think
that nobody in red pill and conservative
has done events well
um now what do I mean I've seen one or
two like singular events cool but what I
want to do is get some Libs and we just
debate them for a week we just debate
for a week straight and and the thing is
you can buy tickets and you can also buy
like season passes and I want I don't
know if this will be in one state or
we'll go City to city or like how it'll
work but I was thinking of box seats and
I I went to a box seat thing with my dad
and I was thinking like there's no box
seats for YouTube like imagine if you
could buy like a box so you could go
with your friends and watch these
debates a lot like I don't know I I just
have ideas
um the events like that that's going to
take me some time I think the next three
months I need to get an email list
together too so that's why I'm working
on the website because
yeah we if we want to Market this stuff
then we gotta we gotta do that but
yeah this is my my comprehensive
rough vision
I'm a visionary
I'm sorry this is very scattered as
usual
um but that's that's what I see going
forward because
I oh back to the CEO I can't manage all
this [__] I just want to go through give
my ideas an input be creative have fun
um but I don't want to deal with that
person's not doing their job I don't
want to deal with oh the revenue is low
in that I don't I don't know how to add
I'm not good with numbers
um I don't want to deal with firing
people I don't really want to deal with
hiring people
I I sit in on interviews all the time
and I just I don't like it I don't like
doing that
um
and then I think I'll need like the CEO
and then I have an idea of people that
will head the different like divisions
or whatever I don't know
I don't want too many people involved I
have a good base of people right now
that I'm like happy with
but I don't know
my dad was saying there's a difference
between like a CEO and a director I
don't really know
um
because
you can have different like managers man
I don't know I don't know this is a
different different day anyway so that's
what I'm looking for in 2023 people have
asked me about hiring
um the best way to get a job honestly to
me is to make it super easy for me to
like meet with you so like again this
recruiter is probably gonna get the job
because he just started working that's
how my second producer fun fact my
second producer I was gonna interview in
England for a second producer he just
got the job because he it was funny he
was interviewing asking me about it and
then he's like oh I can just start
working and he just showed up
and just started working and I was like
oh easy enough
because he went on the show and then
like now he's our second producer and
now he's gonna be full-time next month
hopefully if we have enough work for him
we'll see we'll see but he knows it's a
test he knows
so
because from my end
I'm so busy I hate interviewing people I
just like go-getters that's what I like
and yeah in all honesty it's really not
that hard
to work for me if you make it easy for
me to find you
um another example
trying to think of what I would do
if I
you can also like
send me an invite I hate making Google
invites I just hate doing it
or offer to do a project I mean I'm just
I'm not telling you guys I'm telling you
guys what has worked for me in the past
because I've just gotten a lot of
questions on this
um and for talent
um I really haven't found the right
person yet
um because again a lot of you have to
look at like what makes you special and
a lot of you guys will say you ran these
companies but I I don't when I Google
you I don't find you so it's like you'll
say I ran these multi-million dollar
companies or I made all this money and
I'm like I don't who are you anyways
um yeah that that's my that's my take so
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell and I'll talk to you next time